hey everyone I'm Abby sharp and welcome
to our new series enlightened by
intuitive eating so last week I covered
some frequently asked questions about
intuitive eating and haze and if you
haven't watched the video you can check
it out right here
but basically intuitive eating is a
mind-body framework that was developed
by Evelyn Triple E and Elise rush and
you can get the book intuitive eating
right here it's amazing it will change
your life but basically there are 10
principles they build upon one another
and we're gonna be covering each of them
one by one in this series now before we
get started I want to make it clear that
I am NOT a haze expert and I'm
ultimately not the best representative
to speak on behalf of people in larger
bodies I am still learning myself so I'm
hoping we can kind of learn together and
move towards a more diet free accepting
culture hey everyone Switzerland here I
want to just flag that this intuitive
eating content may not be for all of my
subscribers right now I of course lead
that everyone is welcome to come and
learn about how to eat more intuitively
but I am in no way prescribing this
particular way of eating or thinking I
simply want to share what the research
suggests works
and also what I've seen and practice
work for a lot of people including
myself so this kind of content is not
for you I'm not offended but of course
just know that there will be a lot of
really great content here on Abbey's
kitchen that hopefully is but with all
that said let's get started so as part
of this series I'm going to be answering
one big question that is from you guys
from your comments anything related to
intuitive eating or haze or body
positivity or sighs acceptance etc and
so if you guys have a question please
leave it below and I will consider it
for a future video so let's jump into it
so Dear Abby
I am overweight and my weight is
impacting my health it is very hard on
my joints and I also have diabetes so of
course my doctors all want me to lose
weight isn't it irresponsible to be
promoting intuitive eating and health it
every size to people like me who are
clearly not healthy at my current size
so this is a common criticism of health
at every size and intuitive eating and
here's my professional research informed
opinion weight loss may improve certain
chronic health conditions there is a lot
of correlational research
liking weight loss and improved health
outcomes and in some cases I can't deny
that it may play a role there is even
some research to suggest that modest
weight loss may improve health outcomes
for people living with type 2 diabetes
or at risk of heart disease it's
virtually impossible to tease apart
weight loss from other lifestyle factors
even with something like joint pain
which seems plausible to assume that
losing some weight would improve
outcomes we really don't know how much
of those outcomes are due to something
like physical activity versus the weight
loss itself so of course it's
complicated and I cannot say for certain
that weight is not involved as one of
many different factors the challenge
with the recommendation of course to
just go lose weight is that the research
suggests time and time again that weight
loss diets do not work in fact they
often do more harm than good
and often can cause more weight gain so
some might say that going on in
intentional weight loss diet is a bit of
a risk and benefit analysis and that's
only something that you can decide
whether it's worth doing with your
practitioner and a registered dietician
and to clarify I mean intentional weight
loss restrictive diets I believe that
the goal should be to find a way of
eating that you can comfortably and
pleasurably sustain for the rest of your
life and that is really where intuitive
eating comes into play weight is often
something that we just can't magically
change but behaviors is something that
we can behaviors is something that we
have control over so I would rather
support somebody find behaviors that
they can actually sustain for the long
run then to have them lose some weight
inevitably gain it back and then repeat
the cycle over and over and over again I
just want to add that you know I support
you no matter where you are in this
journey I don't ever ever expect you to
give up the pursuit of weight loss if
that is what brings you better health
and happiness I also don't want to put
weight limitations or restrictions on
who can and cannot practice intuitive
eating I just know what the research
says about fad diets or restrictive
diets in the long term
and I will always believe that it's
better to approach health from a
behavior modification standpoint
behaviors are things that we actually
have control over and we can think of
any weight changes as potential
side-effects okay so I hope that
answered your question
I know it was a bit of a workaround but
basically like I said it's a risk and
benefit analysis that requires you to
kind of make those decisions one-on-one
with your healthcare team and on that
note as the great Julie Andrews would
say let's start at the very beginning a
very good place to start okay that was
she wrote the script I did we're gonna
reject the diet mentality it's number
one it's the first principle let's do it
die culture is all around us and has
affected virtually everyone at some
point in their lives your hairdresser is
talking about keto your mom's cutting
back on the carbs every Instagram
influencer is touting the benefits of
interpret and fasting I mean even the
kids aren't safe what I'm trying to say
is basically everywhere you look
die culture is getting up in your
business it's really no surprise that
upwards of 50% of US adults try to diet
and lose weight every year and trust me
the weight loss industry takes full
advantage of this with keto fat bombs
and whole xxx branded snacks and weight
watchers points on packaging we are
spending more money on fewer calories
and that brings me to intuitive eating
principle number one first and foremost
I want a flag that your health and
happiness are not riding on the size of
your body being smaller doesn't
necessarily mean that you're healthier
and being larger doesn't necessarily
mean that you are less healthy
research suggests that behaviors are
actually a better indicator of health
than body weight so to start to ditch
the diet mentality there are four main
steps that you want to take step one
recognize and acknowledge the damage the
dieting causes sometimes it's hard to
see the damage that dieting does when
the diet industry has rebranded itself
to be all about health in today's age
dieting has become a bad word and has
been replaced with the virtuous pursuit
of wellness and clean
eating don't be fooled this is the same
restrict get that forces us to distrust
our body's needs repackaged with a shiny
new bow regardless of what we call them
diets rarely promote good health some of
the physical harms of chronic dieting
include more intense binges and cravings
increased risk of premature death and
heart disease decreased satiety cues
slower metabolism and changing body
composition with an increase in belly
fat as a result of yo-yo dieting of
course there's also a lot of
psychological harms including an
increased risk of disordered eating
increased stress and anxiety vulnerable
to loss of control surrounding forbidden
foods decreased self confidence and
belief that weight gain is associated
with a flaw in one's character if
someone were to read these side-effects
out to you on a drug pamphlet you would
probably refuse to take it and yet we
pay the diet industry a lot of money
despite all these risks ok so moving on
depth to become aware of diet mentality
thoughts and language remember that dye
culture is so pervasive we often don't
see it there but start to really pay
attention to words thoughts and
behaviors when you approach anything
related to eating exercise or lifestyle
behaviors you want to approach it gently
and with compassion for yourself
thinking about eating in terms of
discipline willpower or self-control may
seem innocent and virtuous but they
often can just re-emphasize the diet
mentality the key thing you need
self-control in order to succeed is
essentially just a die in disguise so
think to yourself why is it that I feel
that I need to have self control over my
eating what is it that makes me feel
that I can't have certain foods when you
try to have self-control and you
inevitably fail when you eat a doughnut
you're characterizing yourself as being
a failure just for eating delicious food
the food you eat or don't eat say
nothing about our character or
self-worth and while the dietary will
try to convince you otherwise you could
be the best person in the world and eat
cupcakes all day or you could be like
the worst human ever and be drinking
kale smoothies for life trust me I know
a lot of these people another thing to
keep in mind is the idea of obedience a
lot of diets even if they don't call
themselves diets often provide a strict
list of foods to eat and foods to avoid
naturally just like with anything else
if we're
hold that we can't have something or do
something our body just wants to rebel
and tends to go overboard when we do so
one of the big problems with these sets
of rules and diets in general is that
they tend to generalize people they
assume that you know we all like eating
the same kinds of foods and we're all
hungry at the exact same time when in
fact we're all very different and our
needs are very different as well some
people are hungry first thing in the
morning while other people cannot stand
the idea of eating anything when they
first get up some people like larger
meals and some people like more frequent
smaller meals throughout the day my
husband and I fit those dichotomies
perfectly and we live under the same
roof but by assuming they're all the
same
diets inherently always will fail us
it's inevitable your body is going to
rebel against a set of rules that was
not designed by you for you how could
you possibly obey them so then what
happens when you fight in rebel well you
might feel good at first when you have
that cupcake but very soon comes those
feelings of guilt and shame with
intuitive eating the goal is to take
charge of your life and your decisions
you decide what feels good you decide
how much your body needs and what your
body needs your body sets the rules by
sitting in the driver's seat you're less
likely to rebel against the rules that
inherently makes your body feel great
what's great about intuitive eating is
that you can't actually fail even if a
snack or meal doesn't go so great or you
eat a little bit more or less than you
think you probably needed to that is
actually banking really important
information for you that'll help you
inform your eating decisions as you move
forward it's a lifelong learning process
that naturally changes as your life
evolves step 3 is to get rid of dieters
tools dieters tools are tools that get
in the way of real progress in our
relationship with food because they
blind us from hearing our body's innate
cues their uses external validation to
tell the person that they're doing
something right so for example a scale
would tell somebody what they weigh if
they see a number that they like it
reinforces a feeling of accomplishment
but if they see a number that they don't
like it often increases a lot of those
bad feelings that we have affiliated
with dieting and pushes self-doubt
Laure self-esteem increases a
preoccupation with food and our body and
also kick-starts the diet cycle over and
over again
I mean raise your hand if you've had a
really great or bad day just based on
the number that you saw on the scale
when you hopped on we've all been there
so in step three these tools need to be
thrown out
so scales any kind of strict meal plans
calorie tracking apps fitbit's anything
that interferes with your relationship
with food should be thrown out and if
you guys have not watched this video
about fitbit's and my experience with
fitbit's you should check it out right
here I want to just note that I am
totally open to the possibility that
calorie counting in some scenarios or
for some populations may have a place I
know that I be really critical of
calorie counting in the past and that's
largely probably rooted in my own kind
of orthotic history however I'm so open
to your feedback and a lot of you noted
that counter counting for a time period
helped you maybe learn some basics of
nutrition or understand how certain
foods make you feel so I totally respect
that and I'm absolutely not dismissing
that potential but for the purposes of
this exercise and ultimately for the
intuitive eating process we need to put
calorie counting on the back burner we
can revisit this of course when we start
talking more about nutrition which is
also a really important part of the
intuitive eating journey however right
now we need to set aside so that we can
learn to trust our body and ourselves
and we can rebuild that relationship
with food now if you're still feeling
anxious and weird about giving these
tools up I want to share with you some
insights into why these tools are really
not the best measurement of health so I
know if not weighing yourself daily
makes you feel like you'll lose tabs on
progress consider that weight really
doesn't tell us all that much like for
example drinking just two cups of water
will equal about one pound so if you
were to eat a little bit of salty chips
and you start to bloat you could easily
step on the scale and assume that you've
gained a ton of weight food also has a
lot of weight so that's why a lot of
times you'll weigh more at the
of the day muscle also weighs more than
fat so if you have a lot of body muscle
you're going to weigh more etc etc etc
and what about those diets that cause
you to lose 10 pounds in one week
well it's largely just water weight and
a little bit of muscle loss when the
muscle breaks down it excretes water as
a by-product which we then excrete into
our urine so the weight that you see
that you lose when you step on the scale
that you are celebrating as an
accomplishment may actually just be
water and muscle which we really don't
want to lose as her calorie trackers and
apps they really are not that accurate
fitbit's and other trackers have
actually been shown to overestimate your
energy expenditure for the day what's
more research has actually found that a
lot of these calorie trackers and
fitness trackers may actually be
detrimental to our mental health one
research study found an association
between calorie trackers or fitness
trackers and eating disorder symptoms
like anxiety around food and eating the
other thing about these trackers is that
they really can only track what you've
done or what you've logged they can take
into consideration if it's a rest day or
if it's your birthday or if it's that
time a month etc they also don't take
into consideration your muscle mass or
metabolism which will have a huge impact
in your energy expenditure and your
energy needs all they can tell you is
whether or not you failed or succeeded
and that is arbitrary at best and
counterproductive at worse to summarize
weighing ourselves can tell us very
little about our health and these apps
really tell us very little about our
body's needs if we want to move towards
honoring our hunger we need to get rid
of these external regulators so to
summarize I'm not saying that you should
never ever again step on a scale I'm
also not saying that you're not allowed
to somehow hope that intuitive eating
will cause you to lose weight I'm just
saying for this process to work and it
is a process we need to put those
thoughts and those tools on the back
burner and that way we can really focus
on rebuilding a trustful relationship
with our bodies and food and finally
that brings me to step number 4 be
compassionate to yourself as you move
forward in this life diet free you're
probably going to be tempted to be
pulled back into diet culture remember
it is everywhere so this is totally
normal so if you're scrolling through
Instagram and you get the feeling or
thought that you want to go on a diet
don't beat yourself up about it
I mean take a minute to think about why
that photo or program or copy or blog
post or whatever incited this thought
also think about whether or not you're
ready to put the restrictive diets on
the back burner right now and if you
think that this is really the best thing
to do both for your physical and mental
health right now remember no judgement
for me we really all have to come into
this when we're ready intuitive eating
takes time and patience you're going to
have setbacks it's inevitable but take
these setbacks as learning up shinee's
rather than failures now if you're
wondering if you're falling back into
diet mentality or how to even identify
diet mentality I want to share a few
really important comparisons that we're
in the intuitive eating book that might
help you along in your journey for
eating and food choices diet talk sounds
like do I deserve it
eating is going to make me feel bad that
food is bad for me that food is good for
me I'm eating clean
in comparison non-diet talk sounds like
am i hungry do I want to eat it am I in
the mood for it
will I be deprived if I don't have it
will it taste good I deserve to enjoy
eating food without feeling any guilt
when it comes to exercise diet talk
sounds like I want to burn as many
calories as possible if I miss a workout
I'm gonna feel bad if I workout for just
another hour then I can work off that
doughnut that I ate earlier
comparatively non diet talk sounds like
exercising makes me feel happy I feel
strong and energized after my workouts
I'm less stress after working out okay
so now that you know the four steps in
the first principle to reject the diet
mentality I want to give you your weekly
exercise so what you're gonna work on
this week is you're gonna clean up your
social media feeds scroll through your
feed and pay attention to diet mentality
so words like clean eating or good food
bad food comparisons or need to earn
your meal or cheat days all of that
should be flagged start to really tune
in to this language and ask yourself how
it feels to see this language and read
this copy or see these images now that
you're trying to think about food and
more
morally neutral terms so if it doesn't
feel like it works for you anymore
unfollow or unsubscribe and fill your
feets with people who have more
supportive relationships with food
remember that intuitive eating is all
about respecting your body's natural
signals and desires
now intuitive eating does fall short and
its ability to describe how trauma
impacts our relationship with food and
our bodies so if this is something that
you were struggling with definitely
reach out to a licensed therapist to get
the support that you need
in the meantime continue to follow at
the intuitive eating series our next
principle is on your hunger so stay
tuned for that if you like this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up leave me a
comment below with any of your questions
related to intuitive eating pays body
positivity etc I will always be making a
running list and I'm gonna be answering
one of those main questions every single
video here subscribe to the channel and
I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]